madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mes chers collègues le
nettoyage ethnique du haut carabak et
ces dizaines de milliers de victimes ne
sont que le premier acte d'une tragédie
qui si les appels de la France ne sont
pas entendus en comportera deux autres
la destruction à l'instigation de la
Russie de la démocratie libérale
arménienne et la remise en cause de la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale d'une Arménie prise en
tenac
par les adeptes du
panturquisme il faut agir je vous pose
madame trois questions pour agir
première question le gouvernement est-il
prêt à saisir à nouveau le Conseil de
sécurité sur les décisions propres
assurer la protection des minorités
arméniennes demeurer au carabach ainsi
qu'à protéger à garantir l'intégrité
territoriale et la souveraineté de la
République de l'Arménie la question des
sanctions doit être légitimement posé
deè question au-delà de l'aide
humanitaire d'urgence le gouvernement
n'estime-t-il pas nécessaire de mettre
en place au niveau de l'Union européenne
un véritable plan Marchal de
réinstallation des réfugiés afin
d'offrir un avenir à ceux qui ont tout
perdu et de faire baisser en Arménie
même une tension susceptible d'emporter
la démocratie 3è question que
comptez-vous faire pour aider l'Arménie
à se défendre entendez-vous répondre
rapidement à sa demande d'armes l'Union
européenne a jusqu'à présent refuser à
l'Arménie la facilité européenne pour la
paix ce refus peut-il enfin être levé
l'honneur de l'Europe est engagé dans
cette tragédie si nous oublions heréan
nous oublions ce que nous sommes et ce
que nous devons rester assez
d'indifférence assez de complaisance
assz de
l'Arménie doit
vivre